yasmin is with us in Virginia hi Yasmine
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi mr. Ramsey no you on this birthday
just great how about you I'm doing fine
thank you for asking
so I am calling to ask how can I prepare
myself financially to perhaps part ways
on my husband and to actually possess
financial freedom I'm a 29 year old
stay-at-home mom with a three-month-old
and I'm completely fed up my husband
just continues to not be honest with me
he's had two cards we possess one one
that I believe is we possess now I just
talked with him about it two days ago
and he says that literally two weeks
before I gave birth to my son I found
out that I was that we were being
evicted based on or due to a ten not
paying rent for and they're not about
$10,000 so as you can imagine my I'm at
my wit's end and I just and like I don't
have any money
yeah so I just need to know what what
should I do financially in order to get
out of this pickle how long you guys
been married we've been married for four
years
are you in a good church I am I am yes
he is - okay here's here's the thing um
there's two possibilities with this guy
your husband mm-hmm it's possible that
he has no idea what he's doing with
money and consequently it's like someone
handing someone the keys to a car to not
drive consequently they would wreck it
before they could get out the driveway
yeah
how old are you guys I'm 29 and he is 31
okay or he is a self-centered jerk who
doesn't care about anything or anybody I
kind of think it's number one I think
he's completely inept does not know what
he's doing
scared to look like a doofus to you
because you're his lady and so he lies
yeah I think that's definitely it he has
the idea that you know he's supposed to
bring home the bacon and handle this and
he doesn't know how correct and he has I
know he makes good money but well okay
so he brings home roughly about mmm for
about four thousand dollars over two
weeks too much to get out too much to
get evicted okay exactly all right so
here's here's what I would suggest you
here's what I suggest you do I would
suggest you go in and sit down with you
and him and your pastor or a marriage
counselor that's on staff at your church
or something like that okay and the two
of you and I think you tell him I think
you're a good man I think your crummy at
handling money if you're gonna continue
to lie to me and do not allow me to be
involved in the handling of the money
and we don't get any help on handling
the money and we're not going to get any
better at handling the money I'm done
I'm leaving today but if you will work
with me and learn how to do this and the
two of us work together and you will
tell me the truth I will stick with you
the rest of our lives absolutely and you
know what he'll bite he'll do it there's
a pastor a pastor's gonna look at him
and box his ears well he we've done this
before and MacArthur's had some pretty
long talks with him regarding
responsibilities but he still handed him
back the keys and he doesn't have
driving instructions so I'm gonna fix
that
part I want the two of you in Financial
Peace University immediately as my guest
I'm gonna pay for it thank you so much
but the may it's mandatory that both of
you go
and that you use this new instruction
and the newfound teamwork of the two of
you working together where you're no
longer ignorant of there anything in the
money piece and both of you learn how to
do something you don't know how to do
right now which is handle money and
there's no shame in that
everyone doesn't know how to do
something I remember the first time I
got behind the wheel of a car almost
tore it up but that should not have
handed an eleven-year-old kid the keys
and not giving them instructions you
know but that's what you do that's what
you do out in the country you just try
stuff out you know so that's kind of how
it feels right now like you guys just
run the thing in the ditch and then you
run it in the other ditch and then you
run it in the other ditch and now the
car is all bent up you know no pun
intended with all the repos at your
house but still yeah if you learn how to
handle money I think your marriage is
going to turn if you learn how to do it
together and Khmer just gonna turn
around really really fast because I
don't think this is a bad guy I think
this is a guy who's ashamed you're right
on that you're right on it absolutely
but he has to he has to push past his
false pride and say I don't know how I
need help and I'm gonna hand him a
driver instruction manual and show him
exactly how to become not just a driver
but a world-class NASCAR driver I'm
going to teach you how to become wealthy
it'll work promise you Financial Peace
University in situations like yours if
you will both embrace it will not only
turn your finances around it'll save
your marriage if you do not do this and
he does not do this you will finish up
becoming the rest of the way disgusted
and you will put together a war chest
somehow and you will leave him because
you're too bright a woman to stay in a
situation this is toxic this is
financial abuse that you're living in
and it's not that he's a mean abuser
he's an angry guy who throws stuff thank
God he's not that guy he's just a guy
doesn't know what he's doing
and there's a whole bunch of guys and
gals out there that don't know what
they're doing no shame in that at all
the only shame is continuing to act like
you know what you're doing and keep
wrecking your car and wondering why hold
on Kelly Oh pick up we'll get you guys
in Financial Peace University I'm gonna
pay for it and you call me back someday
and tell me how good things are going
and someday when you're rich and famous
find some young couple who's scared like
you are right now
and confused like you are right now and
you pay for them to go through financial
piece you pay it forward later okay
meantime I got you back hold on Kelly
I'll pick up